after days of uncertainty and just days
before the Lunar New Year trains are
back on track at this station in Beijing
most passengers are heading south of the
Chinese Capital where towns and cities
are covered in thick snow and slippery
ice what's the use of worrying whether I
get home or not it's not up to
me I believe the government will be able
to handle the problem at the end of the
day I will be able to get
home with more snow the forecast however
clearing the backlog could take time the
blizzards have spared Beijing but that
doesn't mean people here are unaffected
millions are traveling home for the
Lunar New Year holidays so anyone
heading towards Central and Southwest
China where there's been days of heavy
snowfall and freezing rain could
potentially get stranded or
delayed traffic on major highways across
China where at a standstill as cars
broke down and authorities race to
remove snow runways at uhans airport
were forced to shut on Tuesday and
hundreds of trains delayed or suspended
but not only did passengers had to wait
at stations many were also stuck on
trains that lost power at least two
people died in snow related accidents
the central government has released $20
million for ice and snow plowing
operations and as sent relief Goods to
hard hit areas but it's help from local
volunteers that's wared the hearts of
stranded Travelers a re Reon they say to
celebrate even if they don't make it in
time to be with family on New Year's Day
barnab below Al jazer
Beijing make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer